joining me now with more reaction are
former acting ice director tom homan and
arizona attorney general mark bronowicz
thank you both for being here tom i
barely know what to say those numbers 3
million 800 000 50 known but probably a
lot more terrorists that got through
that we don't know about what is to be
said at this point of what we're
watching
you know you know p i've been saying for
a year and a half that this border
crisis would become a national security
crisis of course a lot of people said oh
homie you have no evidence you know what
you're talking about i'm not the
smartest guy on the planet but i know
the border i did it for 35 years i want
to foot stomp the national securities
because here's what we have we have
border patrol arrested people from 161
different countries many of those
countries sponsor terrorism
now if you think not a single one of the
eight hundred thousand got aways
came from the country's monster
terrorism and entered this country was
harm then you're not paying attention
and and that's why he put stompiness and
look after 9-11 i was in dc came up we
created the
the terrorists watch this we created no
fly list we created the visa security
program
and if you get a visa if you get a plan
come to the united states you're vetted
through numerous databases including a
dod database now those databases have
prevented a lot of terrorism come to
this country but they're meaningless
because you're a terrorist now and
you're watching the news
why why buy a plane ticket why apply for
a visa when you know you're gonna get
vetted sure you go to mexico you cross
the southwest board and say the same way
800 000 others did and enter this
country to do us harm this president has
created a border crisis uh an
immigration crisis when you do that that
causes 70 percent of the border patrol
to be off the line
70 percent that's when the drugs flow
through that killed a hundred thousand
americans and that's when the terrorists
come across this is a huge national
security issue and he this president
created this crisis on purpose this is
by design this is open borders
this is open borders uh mr attorney
general
our viewers look at these numbers and
the first thing i think is
two and a half more years of this
what does that look like
um well quite frankly it's the
destruction of america pete look i'm a
first generation american and there's
nothing wrong with people wanting to
come here but they have to do it
lawfully what we have right now at our
southern border is chaos i literally was
down at the southern border just today
talking to the ranchers the people being
impacted by this every day in the tucson
sector there's more than a thousand
there's a thousand getaways just every
single day these are people we don't
know why they're you know not
surrendering to the border patrol
because the administration is allowing
people to come in here and giving them
government benefits housing other social
welfare benefits so what are these
people that are literally crossing the
desert hundred plus degrees going 19 20
miles wearing camouflage dark clothes
the 800 000 that sarah talked about what
intention do they have for our country
border security is indeed national
security and it requires the will to
enforce existing law and pete that's why
i've been in the forefront of filing so
many lawsuits to try to get the bite
administration to do their job and
unfortunately secretary marcus may be
the least competent of anyone in the
buying administration and that's saying
an awful lot in these days
that is saying an awful lot there's a
lot of competition for that spot but it
looks like he's
he's up front tom and mark thank you
both
very much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else